so far when I've talked about the
gradient of a function and you know
let's think about this as a
multivariable function with just two
inputs those are the easiest to think
about so maybe it's something like x
squared plus y squared
very friendly function what I've talked
about the gradient I've left open a
mystery we have the way of computing it
and the way that you think about
computing it is you just take this
vector and you just throw the partial
derivatives in there partial with
respect to X and the partial with
respect to Y with respect to Y and if it
was a higher dimensional input then the
output would have as many as many
variables as you need if it was F of XYZ
you'd have partial X partial Y partial Z
and this is the way to compute it but
then I gave you a graphical intuition I
said that it points in the direction of
steepest descent and maybe the way you
think about that is you have your input
space which in this case is the xy-plane
and you you think of it as somehow
mapping over to the number line
do you have put space and if you have a
given point somewhere the question is of
all the possible directions that you can
move away from this point all those
different directions you can go which
one of them you know the like this point
will land somewhere on the function and
as you move in the various directions
maybe one of them not just your output a
little bit one of them nudges a lot one
of it slides at negative you know one of
them slides at negative a lot which one
of these directions results in the
greatest increase to your function and
this was the loose intuition if you want
to think in terms of graphs we could
look over at the graph of f of x squared
and this is the gradient field all of
these vectors in the xy-plane are the
gradients and you kind of look from
below you can maybe see why each one of
these points in the direction you should
move to walk uphill on that graph as
fast as you can and if you're a mountain
climber and you want to get to the top
as quickly as possible these tell you
the direction that you should move to go
as quickly this is why you call it
direction of steepest ascent so back
over here I don't see the connection
immediately or at least when I when I
was first learning about it it wasn't
clear why this this combination of
partial derivatives has anything to do
with choosing the best direction and now
that we've learned about the directional
derivative
I can give you a little bit of an
intuition so let's say instead of
thinking about you know all the possible
directions and all of the possible
changes to the output that they have so
all fill in my line there you know let's
say you just have you've got your point
or you're evaluating things and then you
just have a single vector now let's
actually make it a unit vector mate
let's make it make it the case that this
guy has a length of one so I'll go over
here and I'll just think of that guys
being V and say the V has a length of
one so this is this is our vector we
know now having learned about the
directional derivative that you can tell
the rate at which the function changes
as you move in this direction by taking
the directional derivative of your
function and let's say this point I
don't know what's a good name for this
point just like a B a B at this point
when you evaluate this at a B and the
way that you do that is just dotting the
gradient of F I should say dotting it
evaluated at that point because gradient
is a vector valued function and we just
want a specific vector here so
evaluating that at your point a B
together with whatever the vector is
whatever that whatever that value is and
in this case we're thinking of V as a
unit vector so this this is how you tell
the rate of change and when I originally
introduced the directional derivative I
gave kind of a Kevin and kind of an
indication why you know if you imagine
dotting this together with and on let's
say it was a vector that's like 1 2
really you're thinking this vector
represents one step in the x direction
two steps in the Y direction so the
amount of their changes things should be
1 times the change caused by a pure step
in the X Direction plus 2 times a change
caused by a pure step in the Y direction
so that was kind of the loose intuition
you can see the directional derivative
video if you want a little bit more
discussion on that and this is this is
the formula that you have but this
starts to give us the key for how we
could choose the direction of steepest
descent because now what we're really
asking
we say which one of these changes things
the most you know maybe when you move in
that direction
it changes f you know a little bit
negatively and we want to know you know
maybe does another vector W is the
change caused by that going to be
positive is it going to be as big as
possible what we're doing is we're
saying find the maximum for all unit
vectors so for all vectors V that
satisfy the property that their length
is 1 find the maximum of the dot product
between F evaluated at that point right
evaluated at whatever point we care
about and V find that maximum well let's
just think about what the dot product
represents so let's say we go over here
and let's say you know let's say we
evaluate the gradient vector and it
turns out that the gradient points in
this direction and maybe it's you know
it doesn't have to be a unit vector it
might be something very long like that
so if you imagine some vector V you know
some unit vector V let's say it was
sticking off in this direction the way
that you interpret this dot product the
dot product between the gradient F and
this new vector V is you would project
that vector directly kind of a
perpendicular projection onto your
gradient vector and you'd say what's
that length
you know what's that length right there
and just as an example it would be
something a little bit less than one
right because this is a unit vector so
as an example let's say that was like
0.7 and then you'd multiply that by the
length of the gradient itself of that of
the vector against which your dotting
and maybe and maybe that guy maybe the
length of the entire gradient vector
just again as an example maybe that's
two doesn't have to be it could be
anything but the way that you interpret
this whole dot product then is to take
the product of those two you would take
0.7 the length of your projection times
the length of the original vector and
the question is when is this maximized
what unit vector maximizes this and if
you start to imagine maybe swinging that
unit vector around so you know if
instead of that guy you were to use one
that point it a little bit more closely
in the direction
then it's projection would be a little
bit longer maybe that projection would
be like 0.75 or something if you take
the unit vector that points directly in
the same direction as that full vector
then the length of its projection is
just the length of the vector itself it
would be 1 because projecting it doesn't
change what it is at all so it shouldn't
be too hard to convince yourself and if
you have shaky intuitions on the dot
product I'd suggest finding the videos
we have on Khan Academy for those Sal
does a great job giving giving that deep
intuition the it should it should kind
of make sense why the vector that points
the unit vector the points in the same
direction as your gradient is going to
be what maximizes it so the answer here
the answer to what vector maximizes this
is going to be well it's it's the
gradient itself right it is that
gradient vector
you know evaluated at the point we care
about except you'd normalize it right
because we're only considering unit
vectors so to do that you just divide it
by whatever its magnitude is if its
magnitude was already 1 it stays 1 if
its magnitude was 2 you're dividing it
down by 1/2 so this is your answer this
is the direction of steepest descent so
I think one thing to notice here is the
most fundamental fact is that the
gradient is this tool for computing
directional derivatives you can think of
that vector is something that you really
want to dot against and that's actually
a pretty a pretty powerful thought is
that the gradient it's not just a vector
it's a vector that loves to be dotted
together with other things that's the
fundamental and as a consequence of this
as a consequence of that the direction
of steepest descent is is that vector
itself because anything if you're saying
what maximizes the dot product with that
thing it's well the vector the points in
the same direction as that thing and
this can also give us an interpretation
for the length of the of the gradient we
know the direction is the direction of
steepest descent but what is the grid
the lengths mean so let's give this guy
a name let's give this normalized
version of it a name I'm just going to
call it W so W will be the unit vector
that points in the direction of the of
the gradient if you take the directional
derivative in the direction of W of F
what that means is the gradient of F
dotted with that W and
you kind of spell out what what W means
here that means you're taking the
gradient of the vector dotted with
itself but because it's W and not not
the gradient we're normalizing or
dividing that not by nine - Dov EV that
doesn't really make sense but by the
value of the gradient and all of these
I'm just writing gradient of F but maybe
you should be thinking about gradient of
F evaluated at a B but I'm just being
kind of lazy and just just writing
gradient of F and the top when you take
the dot product with itself what that
means is the square of its magnitude but
the whole thing is divided by the
magnitude so you can kind of cancel that
out you could say this doesn't need to
be there that exponent doesn't need to
be there and basically the directional
derivative the directional derivative in
the direction of the gradient itself has
a value equal to the magnitude of the
gradient so this tells you one when
you're moving in that direction
in the direction of the gradient the
rate at which the function changes is
given by the magnitude of the gradient
so this is this really magical vector it
does a lot of things it it's the tool
that lets you dot against other vectors
to tell you the directional derivative
as a consequence it's the direction of
steepest descent and it's magnitude
tells you the rate at which things
change while you're moving in that
direction of steepest ascent it's just
really am a core part of scalar valued
multivariable functions and it is it is
the extension of the derivative in in
every sense that you could want a
derivative to extend